everyone thank you for attending it's a
small room thank you for making yourself
comfortable here so i am the posh Roy
and I have with me Austin we both work
at Kaiser Permanente this was one of the
research areas that we thought is very
interesting along the creative analytics
I'm going to go through an outline of
this thing I'm going to talk about the
motivation the philosophy provide you
some definitions this talk was supposed
to be for a novice level so I'm going to
start with very basics so some of you
may be fairly advanced in this I
understand that but we'll start with
very basics he'll go through a little
complicated math Austin is going to take
us there we can go through some examples
on the data sets that we have worked on
and we'll review of a results and the
next steps ok so the motivation majority
of the polenta magnetics today is faizan
historic data as data scientist we
gather data we train the data using
variety of algorithms we test it
validated and finally deploy them all be
there might be way right your ways of
deployment and we can have another
discussion on model deployment
strategies for the purpose of this
discussion I'm taking a different angle
we are talking about situations which
are not trained situations which we
don't have a story data how do we work
with that classic example is a stock
market you come into a situation where
you have not seen something happening
how do we model that and that was the
motivating question behind it and this
is the first step in the research area
that we are doing certainly not the
final I do not have the answers yet but
this is the first step and we have some
data to prove that okay we are moving in
the right direction I'm going to start
with philosophy and I'm going to keep it
entertaining so I'm going to ask you
guys questions okay this is an easy
question who said this so far as the
laws of mathematics refer to reality
they are not certain and so far as they
are certain
they do not refer to reality anyone
perfect perfect since you know this
answer i'm going to ask you a difficult
one now XCOM plex city rises precision
precise state wins lose meaning and
meaningful statements lose precision now
this is dr. lot fees are there he is one
of the pioneers in fuzzy logic he took
the work from he's from UC Berkeley by
the way he took the work from dr.
Dempster's and sheppard and then he
extended it institute in certain books
on uncertainty reasoning as well and his
work is is very well respected in AI
especially kind of things good try thank
you for trying I'm going to talk about
very basic definitions and I'm sure
everybody is going to get this answer
but I still have to start somewhere I
have a box a box has 16 apples eight big
eight small i am going to randomly pick
an apple there is uncertainty about the
size of the apple that will come out the
size of the apple can only take two
values can anybody tell me what is the
probability that can be a big apple
this is data science yeah he's saying
something it's fifty percent okay no
breaks it's okay so there are two
distinct possible outcomes and your
random variable can take one of the two
values big or small so there is this is
randomness this is uncertainty now we
talk about fuzziness now there is a box
of 16 apples these apples are of
different sizes and now I am asking you
to take apple in your hand like this guy
and you're asked what is is this a big
apple or a small app it's hard to
quantify this because it does not belong
to a label size and as data scientists
we do a lot of labeling we do this very
often data we characterized in two sets
basically but this is fuzzyness so this
is what we are talking about the fuzzy
area and when Austin visit that will go
into details of the math about it he
will show up on sonnet a certainty zone
which is the fuzzy area okay think
everybody is on the same page now okay
so why did I select Dempster Shepherd
method a couple of things Dempster
Shepherd was used in AI a lot and then
reliability modeling and I have some
links and that is a whole list of
references you can reach out to me later
on I can give you the details on the
references as well it led to the path of
fuzzy logic I wanted to go to the basic
algorithms of dempster Shepherd and see
how I could integrate it with our
regular predictive modeling algorithm
and thanks to my interns who did work
with me and spent days and nights on it
without them I would not have validated
a few of them so that was the basic
principle why I wanted to go behind him
session
so also Dempster Schaefer is
generalization of bees in theory of
subjective probabilities are there any
frequent test in this room or
everybody's bayesian here okay so base
in theory I mean requires probability
for each question of interest however
using Dempster Shepherd theory i can get
degrees of belief and degrees of belief
is strength of evidence in favor of some
proposition I take it for one question
and I can use it for a related question
so i take my knowledge for one question
and as anybody related question and i
have put some links down there for
people to use it or look at it later on
so that was why Dempster Shepherd and
I'm going to give you a brief history
about Dempster sheffer Before we jump
into the actual math and details about
it so it has its roots in 17th century
in some form people were talking about
it 1968 dr. Dempster at Harvard actually
came up with a way of combining beliefs
76 the Dempster Shepherd theory was
created I the standards before majority
of people here ever born but this theory
was actually criticized a lot because it
was combining probabilities of truth
with probabilities of probability so
that was criticism on it and we didn't
see much work but last few years there
have been more and more researchers
talking about a talking about how to use
this and stuff like that especially the
last two papers were pretty good about
what them suffer can do and how can we
combine evidence we are reaching a stage
where we have enough data to now model
uncertainty to some extent there is
still a lot of room to cover here okay
I'm going to take talk about some basic
examples and then we are going to go to
the math so Dempster Shepherd theory has
to come
one is obtaining degrees of belief and
combining the Dickie Sutphen and I'll
explain you what is the degree of belief
again so let us start with a story I
have a friend Betty I think she is
pretty much reliable she is ninety
percent of the times reliable so I give
subjective probabilities to her ninety
percent point nine is unreliable ten
percent point one she calls me and she
tells me hey a limb fell on your car she
is a reliable friend so there is no
reason for me to worry about why would
she say that or so I take her testimony
alone and say that I give you a point
nine degree of belief that a limb fell
on my car based on the subjective
probability and a zero believe that no
limb fell on my car in this case the
belief functions is between zero point
nine and zero perfect so the zero degree
of belief here does not mean that I am
sure that no limb fell in my car it
merely means that based on Betty's
testimony I have no reason to believe
that a limb fell on mega and this is the
part where it was criticized because now
you are giving probability instead of
probabilities of truth the degree
function you are giving so you have
subjective probability 0.9 and point one
but my degree believe function the
strength of evidence is point nine and
zero degree of belief for me there is no
reason to disbelieve
yeah I just use her statements i do not
use the actual events perfect okay now
let's have more fun so I have another
friend named Sally Sally is also
reliable friend she's reliable ninety
percent of times and unreliable ten
percent of times she independent of
Betty comes and tells me hey a limb fell
on my car so there are two people saying
the same thing and I'll just do the
probability math and keep it easy here
is both our probability that both are
reliable is 0 point 9 in 2.9 is point 8
1 probability neither of them is
reliable is 0 point 0 1 and probably
that at least one is libelous point 0 99
so this is basic at least 1 probability
since both said a limb fell on my car at
least one of them being reliable I say
that this event has a degree of belief
4.99 based on the least one okay so this
is a scenario where they both agree with
each other and now I'm going to the next
scenario where they both contradict each
other okay Sally contradicts Betty Sally
tells me that no limb fell on my car so
in this case both of them cannot be
reliable because one has to be
unreliable so now we go into something
called as prior versus posterior
probabilities anybody everybody knows
what's a prior so if for some people who
don't know what's a prior is existing
state if you are a computer scientist
it's the state 0 and then you go to
state 1 is like a state diagram so think
of it that way so prior is the existing
state so Betty is reliable Sally is not
we multiply the probabilities is
straightforward solace reliable Betty is
not be multiply the probabilities state
forward neither of them are reliable
it's easy now we go to a posterior state
the posterior state is a state where
provided at least one is reliable so the
probability that Betty is reliable and
Sully is not divided by the probability
that at least one is reliable unreliable
we get 9 x 19
and we do the same thing for Sally we
get 9 x 19 so we have 9 x 19 degree of
belief that a limb fell on my car what
is liable and 9 x 90 degree of believe
that no limb fell on my car and Sally's
level so this is my belief function area
we can go through the math if you have
questions I can sit with you I can show
you what we did and we can give you the
references from this where this was as
well so what what we are trying to show
here is you obtain degrees of belief for
one question did a limb fell on my car
from the probabilities of another
question is the witness reliable ok so
just we have moved something and this is
the basic example dr. Dempster actually
gave in his class in 2001 what we will
do now Austin will basically take us to
the mat and then he will take us to the
examples that we simulated and show us
the results Joslyn will go next I need
to give you this
hello everyone so I'm going to go into
the you know kind of where we're going
with this whole project that was kind of
watching the great job of laying the
groundwork for it so whenever you know
you start on some kind of obscure
project it's kind of nice to know like
what your objectives are in the first
place and so really kind of the main
motivation in case it wasn't obvious
already is just we're trying to find
like a fuzziness prediction so if you
have some sort of probability you know
you make some probability statement like
there's a point five or something like
that probability of something happening
and for example in logistic regression
you can produce probabilities but what
it can't do is maybe provide some like
interval for uncertainty for those
probabilities so maybe an example of how
that might be useful I was thinking
about is possibly if you have you know a
lot of people have a cutoff of point
five where you would classify for a
binary prediction either one class or
the other so if you had to say a point
not 49 probability for one observation
for example perhaps if you had some
uncertainty around that probability it
might cover your boundary line where
you're going to classify it
as say 01 so that's kind of what we're
going for and then since it is kind of
this unexplored territory a little bit
we'd like to see if it actually does any
better than the logistic regression
which is I should point out art we're
using as our prior that de poshi-ne
deuced you so what we're doing is we're
taking right now logistic regression as
our prior information but another
algorithm could be used there's there's
nothing that tide is to data then it's
just kind of you know the first thing
you go to because it's so fast quick and
easy so these are kind of the proof for
you know what we've kind of validated
that we're on the right track so far
these are the different data sets or I'm
sure some of you have seen them before
most from our firm UCI machine learning
data repository for sharon's familiar
with that some of them were kind of
weird but you know it's basically we
just were looking for a binary response
variable that we wanted to test on so
just kind of you know maybe just a
high-level overview of the trends we've
seen so far we've done some like
statistical validation but you know
there's just so many different you know
things to do basically when you're
trying to create this kind of new thing
that you know we're still working on
validating it it does it does increase
some performance metrics that we've
tested one thing we have on our list is
to add more a comprehensive list of
different metrics just so it can be
rigorous on our testing
in and so the algorithm is not black box
you know if you understood the examples
the posh gave you I think they're fairly
straightforward then that's that's kind
of what you need to know as far as the
algorithm we're just doing kind of a few
little things that are different which
I'll go over as I mentioned before the
prior probabilities can come from other
algorithms other than logistic
regression which is kind of cool and
there's more even thinking possibly old
bring in multiple prior algorithms going
forward we want to see how it scales so
you know we're going to actually get any
you know tangible results from this if
we wanted to scale it up the Dempster
schaeffer's basically it emphasizes
agreement so in the case of the two
friends when a limb fell in the car you
know it wants to emphasize you know
where they agree on certain issues on
whether a limb fell and the Pasha's car
or not so if you have highly imbalance
classes sometimes it will look for too
much agreement when maybe there isn't
that much agreement and then we do want
to test different prior algorithms so
anyone's taking a probability class were
kind of in the data science atmosphere
or some perceive taking 1 i'm pretty
sure you've taken or done sort of
problem with marbles in a jar or i think
they still use the term urn we're going
to soon we're going to say instead of
taking a marble out of the urn you know
what's the probability of getting red or
blue marble we're going to turn that to
a binary situation and just say what's
the majority of of colors and the jar so
it's I picked one of you out of the
audience and ask you what do you think
the majority is let's assume there's
more marvelous and there is now but you
would maybe i would guess getting some
sort of answer like i think probably
read or i think probably blue maybe i
could push you a little further and i
could give you kind of get you to give
me your degree of belief so you know
maybe quantify your belief a little bit
more and let's say I picked two people
out of the audience and I wanted to kind
of merge that information a little bit
then ideally I would get more informed
opinion of what the majority of colors
in the jar is so let's say they did that
let's say the first person the
conversation went something like the
majority of colors in the jar is red and
they're able to quantify that at seventy
percent maybe think there's half half
and there's a ten percent or 10 degree
belief of that and then let's say that
they're willing to quantify that they're
actually wrong in this case you could
say and that's at twenty percent and I
go to person to person tues not quite so
sure they say fifty percent a majority
being read and I just want to point out
it's a little interesting because if you
have like to kind of outcomes you know
if you say fifty percent chance of one
happening then you normally say okay
well 5050 either way but with this kind
of fuzzy logic idea technically person
to could only give me an answer of fifty
percent and then as to Pasha's example
where there's that zero someone asked
about they can just kind of leave the
rest on it said but let's say they did
fill in the rest of that one hundred
percent and they said half blue read
that twenty percent and then that they
were wrong at thirty percent so one
initial guess if you were just talking
to these people and you say okay well it
seems like the majority is red maybe you
would average the two majorities from
those two people and you come out at
like sixty percent right but Dempster
Schaefer actually finds that agreement
so we get a much larger degree of final
degree of belief for the majority of
colors in that jar being red and it
looks you can kind of see kind of steals
I guess you could say some of the degree
of belief from that half half situation
because we don't have that much
agreement so it's kind of penalizing a
little bit the disagreement between
those two people so I just want to give
that example I'll try and refer back to
it as I go to the math part a little bit
i'm not going to really go into much
detail but basically this
the stuff right here that's kind of
where we're are merging our two beliefs
and in order to do that so a is for
example to the mortgagee of colors in
the jar is red and then B and C are just
some other propositions that we have so
we're kind of you know multiply them
together I like to posh it a little bit
and then we're kind of adding them all
together to get one final kind of merged
belief and then we're kind of you can
say normalizing a little bit by this one
minus a degree of conflict so we're kind
of normalizing by some sort of agreement
so again emphasizing agreement between
different sources of information okay is
the measure of conflict yeah and if you
want to ask questions about two
you kind of say that it's it's a little
simpler when there's like a binary case
and one of the other is that we might
want to take this is extending it to a
multi-class cage which gets much more
complicated because so in terms of like
the marble example we're thinking about
what the majority of colors is so if we
have like a majority of colors being
read the similarities are where we have
to some subspace basically of some
hypothesis is that am I getting
I it gets yeah yeah yeah it's pretty
this part is like nothing especially new
I'm department over the history of
additives and we have references to that
are pretty good go over and why we're on
just kind of the you know the main
Dempster Shaffer stuff really what we
wanted to focus on is that interval so
there's the insurgent eat the Polish
mentioned and just defining what what it
would is a belief and a good way to
think about it just a strength of
evidence in favor of some propositions
so if we want to find out what is a
proposition for majority of colors of
marble in a jar that's going to be our
belief so kind of what it sounds like
plausibility is something we haven't
talked about but that's important
because you know if you have a certain
belief of colors in a jar in order to
get that uncertainty we kind of have to
acknowledge that there's events I guess
you could say that that we're not
considering so that's that that range
that we're really kind of interested in
for probabilities that are coming out
and then belief in the complement of a
so that's again kind of the situation
where did the branch fall in the car did
it not if they only say the branch fell
on a car and they leave the rest on said
then we don't necessarily have that
conflict or that complement sorry again
kind of going fairly quickly through
this this is the where we go from being
Dempster Shaffer to a modified Dempster
Shaffer with
the use of prior information in evidence
space again its ongoing research but
possibly using source different sources
of prior algorithms but essentially what
we're doing to get that updated so again
we're taking the prior probability which
in this case is represented by P of a so
a being for example majority of colors
and in the jar are red and then we're
normalizing that over all the other
different propositions that we're
considering so what does that actually
look like back to the marbles again
what's the majority of colors we have
the same two people if we take in now
instead just doing regular denser
schaefer we take in a modified denser
schaefer you notice that the strength of
belief for majority of colors in the jar
being red has has gone up so it would be
I think a fair assumption to guess
without knowing anything else that the
prior information you had was in favor
of the majority of colors and a jar
being read and in fact that's true for
the calculation for these particular
numbers because so actually maybe a real
life example that I thought of for this
particular cases maybe knew beforehand
that the manufacturer of marbles makes
you know ratio of three to two red
marbles so it'd be information going
into whatever belief you want to have
about this particular problem so this is
kind of the framework of our algorithm
basically of course we have training in
test set the only thing that we're
taking from our training set is what our
logistic regression algorithm the
probabilities that came out of that so
again doesn't have to be logistic
regression it could be some other
algorithm and that's going into the
modified part so where it gets a little
more complicated than the examples we've
gone over so far is that we don't have
like a panel people kind of saying for
each observation what they think their
strength of belief is and so our
features are basically are our people so
we need to get those
of belief from individual people and
endure dude that we have to artificially
create them I'll go over kind of how we
do that in the next slide but we're
essentially partitioning each feature
based on min and Max values so after we
bring in the prior algorithm the prior
probabilities for from the training set
becomes modified with prior
probabilities we do some incorporating
hypothesis stuff which you don't really
have to worry about the technical part
but basically we're that interval that I
showed you before we're trying to just
bring in that information about what the
algorithm is saying it believes in
addition to the uncertainty and penalize
the probabilities based on how much
belief there is and and one observation
or disbelief and then we reclassified
the data with updated probabilities so
this is kind of how we artificially
create those math values so for a given
feature or column we have three
different situations this is one of them
we partition each data by class so if
you know you just want to say zero and
once it's a binary in this situation we
have the classy oh eclipsing the class
one so that's one situation and then
depending on which region each
observation files to we're going to
assign it a mass value believe disbelief
and in certain cases uncertainty so now
on to kind of what we've actually done
so far we've tested as a farm for two
datasets mostly from UCI machine
learning repository and then there's
also in our package called data sets and
then also not listed here is played
around a little bit with Higgs boson
data set so email spam is it spam or is
it not spam I think the way it works for
this particular data set is a bunch of
people send in their spam to
a curator and basically telling you that
person if it's bambor not spam so we
have 4,600 authorizations for which for
the data sets that we tested on was kind
of on the large side granted isn't
really that large but I think it does
have quite a few features on it if you
think of that in terms of kind of what
the denser Schaefer is trying to do
where we're merging and trying to
strengthen belief in a certain
proposition more features is better
because you have kind of more
overlapping potential evidence so for
this particular data set we did pretty
well and what I'm trying to show you is
not initially like our algorithm is like
wow it's doing awesome and everything
I'm just trying to kind of highlight the
feeling that we've gotten so far from
the data sets because we've only done
some statistical testing so it's not
like fully rigorous or anything but in
this particular case it's it's fairly
representative of what we've seen you
know we did better in accuracy a lot of
times when there's actually no change at
all between what we're comparing to
which is the lr logistic regression as
compared to our algorithm which is the
logistic regression then stir Schaffer
so it tends to do better on true
positives worse on false positives for
kind of evaluation over different values
we chose to use up he our curves so
basically the takeaway from this picture
is that light blue is better than dark
blue so there again they're really
similar but our are just realize the
title is wrong if that's okay our PR
curves are are better for our logistic
regression not a by a whole bunch but
significantly so so go example I want to
show you guys is from a cardi attic
single proton emission computed
tomography images and we're predicting
on basically where there is a normal or
abnormal heart an interesting thing
about this data set actually is it's
entirely binary so I guess the way it
worked is a bunch of different people
showing different images and they said
you know of different parts of the brain
and they basically said is it abnormal
looking them or not and then so we have
23 I think different people looking at
these different images and then our
responses you know final is it are we
looking at abnormal heart or not so
that's our response this one had a much
smaller observations and I think from a
theoretical side this algorithm it maybe
doesn't matter so much on actually the
size of the data set because we're not
taking too much information you know
it's not like a tree where you you kind
of build your tree and then you apply it
to some new today is that we're not
actually taking too much information
from our training data sets just those
prior probabilities so it may not change
is kind of how it's looking now again
it's under research but may not change
too much for scaling tune-up and then
this is one of the better examples where
we pretty much succeeded in every metric
that we tested except for the false
positives the only reason I'm showing
you this one is because you there's
really no noticeable difference between
the two PR curves which is kind of
interesting given that it's you know it
was doing so much better in the
different metrics but I just wanted to
show you this one because it to me it
just showed that you know it's not just
kind of a random fluke that we're
getting we're getting really
consistently high performance and our
different metrics that we're testing
they're actually all above that diagonal
line so anything above the line is in
favor of our algorithm and anything
below the line and for the AUC you is
actually exactly the same and here's our
references I'm not sure how I'm doing on
time but that's basically all we had for
you today
to the UCI reconsider yeah we wanted and
that's
so what we are re to think about regular
leaving us so long with a fryer you add
a custom along with probability you add
one so you can take any algorithm for
that matter what we did we took that
email for the first fan yay or nay we
started with very simple you wanted to
keep it only to two classes so that's
where you have yen as we go into
multiple classes but we'll have to
change the way we are doing stuff that's
in our roadmap you have to write
something little more sophisticated than
what we have today and again this is
like a point in time right now that we
are in classification and you're going
to see how
I mean all you are good with us and what
I'm trying to do
think of scenarios the new high score
and that the patch of I when I started
with job I got about 9 11 fellas what we
are modeling and what I am adding
so yeah that's a good way
we are trying to see that what happened
I mean it probably will go to work
we will be able to give some kind of
grief that okay this needs you to attend
I am not aware so he takes action for
that situation will have a human
activity before we take a sh not just
follow the nom de score that's at say
that
you are
so I their ears and the mud tug the goal
is we sounds idea super bouncy house
with other people also to do some down
sampling and taking this is the question
then it comes is if there is a 100
chance of something happening because
it's highly uncommon Peter said now you
are down sampling it and bringing it to
like 1 by 4 or something like that and
when you look at the statistics part of
it you feel that there is something
wrong going on so I am still working on
that I don't have an answer for that
right now but yeah that is I think
that's the question fit with majority of
apartments because when it comes to a
highly unbalanced data set he's
algorithm known for formats good I mean
there is some science it's not out of
the box anymore
they're definitely like as far as like
we have to leave
and i'll be happy
try out this thing so this is new area
and I guess we'll be publishing this
first paper on this is men let me know
all that goes
you